zdf heute live willkommen in berlin hat
sich ein unfall ereignet zumindest muss
man es ist momentan so nennen denn
genaue hintergründe sind noch nicht
bekannt was wir wissen ist ein auto
fährt in eine menschenmenge ob gezielt
oder ein unfall ist zur stunde noch
nicht zu sagen schalten wir nach berlin
und machen uns ein bild von dem was wir
zur stunde wissen carsten behrendt unser
reporter ist vor ort hallo carsten ein
ort über den man noch reden muss das
machen wir gleich weil natürlich werden
sofort erinnerungen wach an das was da
vor sechs jahren geschah aber bleiben
erstmal am tag heute schilder uns was
kann man zur stunde gesichert sagen
ja wir stehen hier auf dem
breitscheidplatz dann fuß direkt der
berühmten
kaiser-wilhelm-gedächtniskirche hinter
mir befindet sich die straßenkreuzung
kurfürstendamm rankestraße town ziehen
und wir sehen hier hinter mir dort liegt
eine mülltonne eingerahmt von zwei
abgesperrten stühlen da soll um 10 uhr
30 ein mann wie wir inzwischen wissen
ein 60 jähriger mann mit seinem renault
clio in die menschenmenge auf der
anderen straßenseite gefahren sein er
ist dann wohl wieder zurück auf die
straße
ist noch wir können ja auch mal rüber
schwenken etwa 150 200 meter noch kurz
auf der straße gefahren dann wieder auf
den gehweg zurück und dann
indem fensterscheibe einer drogerie
eines paar firmen laden zum stehen
gekommen es gibt nach aktuellem stand
einen toten und mehrere schwerverletzte
12 hatte die polizei als letzte zahl
genannt und davon sind fünf
schwerstverletzten 30 faktisch ich habe
jetzt neben mir gerade nicht nämlich
stehen thilo kablitz kann man ihn gleich
dazu holen natürliches träger klar nur
zu ok kilo kablitz sie sind der polizei
pressesprecher kommen sich ein kleines
bisschen näher sie waren hier relativ
schnell mit einem wirklich großaufgebot
an beamten unterwegs sie sagen 150
beamte schwert bewaffnet sehen wir mit
maschinenpistolen mit helmen
behandeln sie das ganze als unfall oder
nehmen sie aufgrund dieses orts wo er
sich ja dieser schwere terroranschlag
ereignet hat 2016 nehmen sie diesen
vorfall anders war und bearbeiten noch
anders natürlich gehen wir hier mit
gebotener
aufmerksamkeit dran es geht um ein
ereignis gerade an diesem ort sie haben
es gerade gesagt an dem ort werden die
wunden die in die stadt gerissen wurden
oder wir haben eigentlich nie wieder
verheilen und natürlich betrachten wir
das auch unter dem gesichtspunkt es
gehört aber grundsätzlich dazu wenn wir
eben die motivation noch nicht geklärt
haben ob eine motivation vorliegt oder
ist es lediglich um einen verkehrsunfall
handelte der unter einem jahr dem
schatten eines medizinischen
ausnahmezustands beim fahrer vielleicht
stand solange das nicht geklärt haben
müssen wir einfach mit
vorsichtsmaßnahmen rangehen es wäre
fatal wenn wir die eine version annehmen
und auf der anderen seite dann blind
werden so wie sich der ablauf bislang
uns darstellt was so dass er hier auf
höhe der rankestraße
eine mülltonne gerammt hatte liegen wir
sehen wir da auch noch liegen dann wohl
aber auch wieder zurück auf die straße
gefahren ist und dann noch eine ganze
strecke zurückgelegt hat können sie das
bestätigen oder gibt es da neue
erkenntnisse dazu wie sich das ganze
zugetragen hat und wo auch die
verletzten zu beklagen sind es ist
tatsächlich so dass wir jetzt in der tat
oder ein ereignis rekonstruktion sind
von daher kann ich ihnen noch nicht
abschließend ein bild zeichnen also
grundsätzlich so dass die personengruppe
sich kuhfuß und amecke rankestraße auf
dem gehweg sehr genau hinter ungenau
befunden haben soll da ist er in die
personengruppe eingefahren hatte aber
mehrere verletzt eine person wurde ja
auch getötet
einiges schwer verletzt dann ist er kurz
auf die fahrbahn wieder auf den gehweg
gekommen und von diesem gehweg aus dann
in dem geschäft zu stehen bekommen also
durch die schaufensterscheibe
eingedrungen in das objekt und dort zum
stehen gekommen sie sagten in ihrer
ersten meldung sie haben den fahrer wie
wir inzwischen wissen einen 60 jahre
alten mann festgehalten nicht
festgenommen
ist das ein bewusst gewähltes gewählte
begriff nein in dem fall tatsächlich
festgehalten war tatsächlich
passantinnen und passanten nach meinem
kenntnisstand als erste person da vor
ort gewesen sein sollen und ihn
festgehalten haben also tatsächlich
physisch festgehalten haben sollen und
wir dann tatsächlich als polizeiliche
aktion festgenommen haben es heißt der
mann befindet sich im moment auch ein
medizinischer betreuung ist der
vernehmungsfähig können sich etwas
zusammen zustand sagen zu dem
gesundheitszustand habe ich jetzt
aktuell noch nichts mir wurde vorher
mitgeteilt dass er unter dem einfluss
des ereignisses stand inwieweit das
jetzt tatsächlich mit einem
verkehrsunfall korrespondiert oder eben
mit einer tatmotivation die dem zugrunde
liegt einer vorsatztat das kann ich
ihnen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht sagen
wir haben von augenzeugen gehört dass
der mann wohl auch noch vor und zurück
gefahren sein soll legen ihn dazu
erkenntnisse vor zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
tatsächlich nicht deshalb befinden sich
also viele einsatzkräfte auch hier nicht
nur um der den ereignisort abzusichern
sondern auch tatsächlich um die tat zu
rekonstruieren wir haben ermittlerin und
ermittler wir haben unser verkehrsunfall
kommen nur hier die jetzt die spurenlage
hier erheben die zeuginnen und zeugen
befragen und dann ist es ganz ganz
wichtig eben nicht eine singuläre
zeugenaussagen zu nehmen sondern
unterschiedliche übereinander zu legen
und da diese schnittmenge die sich
daraus bildet die bildet eigentlich die
realität dann schon sehr gut ab dann
erfüllt wenn wir das ganze an mit eben
der beweislage wie der spurenlage vor
und haben dann auch eine belastbare
aussage oder können dann auch eine
belastbare aussage zum hergang des
ereignisses das heißt also wir wissen
noch nichts zu den gründen dafür wir
wissen aber das ist wirklich sehr
schwerwiegender vorfall ist eine person
wurde getötet
sie sagten von zwölf verletzte
vielleicht können wir noch mal die
zahlen
aktualisieren dass wir da auch nichts
falsches sagen auch die zahl der
schwerstverletzten was können sie uns
dazu sagen da müsste ich an die
feuerwehr tatsächlich verweisen also
nach meinem kenntnisstand mehr als zwölf
personen die verletzt wurden mindestens
vier schwer verletzt und eine person die
getötet wurde die belastbaren zahlen hat
tatsächlich dann die feuerwehr weil die
eben genau für die erstversorgung und
die weitere versorgung in der zuständig
ist nun hat die berliner polizei auch
nach diesem schweren terroranschlag der
sich hier genau auf der anderen seite
der gedächtniskirche
ereignet hat auch viel verbessert viel
gelernt auch zusammen mit den anderen
rettungsdiensten ersthelfern was wenden
sie jetzt an von dem was sie an
erkenntnissen aus diesem anschlag
gezogen haben tatsächlich alle
komponenten wir sind sehr früh zum
beispiel eine entsprechende führungs
phase übergegangen das hat erst mal
nichts mit mit erkenntnissen zu einem
etwaigen
einer etwaigen vorsatz tat zu tun
sondern einfach damit mit gewissen
indikatoren mehrere personen verletzt
ereignisort eigenes zeit all das fließt
mit ein und da wurde dann entsprechende
phase einführungsphase ausgerufen so
dass schnell direkt eine koordination
des einsatzes stattfinden kann kräfte
gesteuert werden können kräfte dann auch
tatsächlich unterschiedlich eingeteilt
werden können sie hat uns angesprochen
es gibt hier welche mit
schutzausstattung und auch der mp
natürlich ist das dann auch bestandteil
einfach von sicherungs oder
schutzmaßnahmen die wir eben aus den
erfahrungen die wir leider alle ziehen
mussten gelernt haben sie habe auch eine
psychosoziale betreuung eingerichtet
haben wir gehört ja ganz genau ist auch
bestandteil einer eines solchen
ereignisses nur dass sie dass die
menschen die zeugen geworden sind im
moment betreut werden können von
seelsorgern ganz genau darum geht es
denn auch das zählt dazu auch da stehen
wir in der verantwortung nicht nur für
die sicherheit im allgemeinen sondern
auch eben dafür die betreuung von
betroffenen nachrichten dann wären wir
dann mehr informationen bekommen wie
lange werden sich die ermittlungen jetzt
hinziehen sie uns vielleicht mehr sagen
können auch zu einem möglichen motiv ob
sich wirklich im unfall oder um eine
vorsätzliche tat handelt die ermittlung
hier vor ort und die erhebung der
spurenlage wird sicherlich mehrere
stunden in anspruch nehmen ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob schon aufgebaut wurde
aber häufig werden bei solchen ereignis
orten auch 3d messgeräte aufgebaut also
die lasermessgeräte die dann tatsächlich
eine 3 die moderation der des
ereignisses ortes auch am computer
ermöglichen so dass wir die tat oder das
ereignis noch besser rekonstruieren
können ergab jetzt vielen dank das ist
der polizeipressesprecher in berlin dass
sie uns die rede und antwort gestanden
haben wir werden uns sicherlich heute im
laufe des tages noch öfter sehen
erstmals für den moment vielen dank und
ehre zurückgeben nach mainz noch die
info dass auch bei den senatoren
sicherheits von politischer seite
gemeldet hatte sie sagt sie sei im
lagezentrum beobachtet dort die
situation weiter und sie sei tief
bestürzt über das was hier passiert sein
karsten vielen dank wir machen natürlich
noch ein bisschen weiter weil wir noch
ein bisschen auch die stimmung anfang
wollen aber danke auch an dieser stelle
an den polizeisprecher carsten bleibt
bei uns du hast mich noch häufig
wir versuchen uns nochmal carsten
behrendt dass wir so genau passen wir
wollen noch ein bisschen weiter machen
danke dass wir haben noch zeit und vor
allem haben wir auch noch fragen wie wir
die wir gerne noch klären wollen aber
das war natürlich schon mal ein erster
überblick über das was man momentan
sagen kann aus sicht der polizei aber
was mich natürlich auch interessiert du
bist live vor ort und vor allem dass das
damals 2016 auch alles sehr hautnah und
und sehr intensiv miterlebt weil du da
auch der reporter fürs zdf war es der an
dem tag zu der zeit dort war aber bevor
wir wie gesagt ab 2016 schauen zeigt und
erzählt uns noch ein bisschen wie
erlebst du diesen ort momentan wir sehen
flatterband wir sehen viel polizei aber
was spürst du oder wie wie ist die sorge
und und die befindlichkeit der zeit
ja die bei uns sind natürlich bei allen
der redaktionen sofort die alarmglocken
angegangen als wir gehört haben
autounfall schwer verletzte und
breitscheidplatz diese kombination die
sitz den berliner natürlich immer noch
in den knochen auch werden dieser
schwere anschlag jetzt fünfeinhalb jahre
her ist aber der ist natürlich nicht
vergessen und als ich hier angekommen
bin bin ich direkt an der gedenkstätte
vorbei gelaufen denn dieser unfall der
hat sich auf der anderen seite der
gedächtniskirche die gedächtniskirche
wird ja eingerahmt von zwei großen
straßen und auf genau auf der anderen
seite auf der identischen höhe ist
dieser mann mit seinem trio in die
menschen gefahren und auch wenn wir im
moment noch nichts wissen über die
motive aber die erinnerungen sind dann
natürlich sofort wieder da und ich denke
so geht es heute vielen berlinerinnen
und berlinern dass sie denkt nein bitte
nicht schon wieder wir schauen hier
gerade mal auf die karte die ich hier
aufgemacht wenn wir uns das anschauen
wollen berlin wirklich innenstadt jeder
der schon mal da war wirklich hier
direkt an der an der am kudamm wir sehen
hier da wo du jetzt stehst hier drüben
ist sozusagen das mahnmal die
gedächtniskirche breitscheidplatz das
ist alles vis á vis und wenn wir uns
hier diese diese kreuzung anschauen wo
du gerade stehst und wie du es gerade
beschrieben hast ist es sozusagen auch
schon die räumliche nähe zu dem was 2016
geschehen ist die natürlich diese
erinnerung direkt wieder hervorruft von
dem was du momentan sagen kannst wie
dieser weg des autos war also einerseits
in die richtung die uns vorhin gezeigt
hast dann aber noch mal zurück und dann
in die andere richtung auch da nicht
sozusagen vorhersagen was der grund
dafür sein kann aber es ist kein gerader
weg habe ich das richtig verstanden es
ist nicht eine gerade linie die das auto
genommen hat
also der polizeisprecher hat ja gesagt
das wird im moment noch ermittelt wir
haben das von zeugen berichten gehört
dass das auto aus der menschenmenge oder
von dem gm wieder zurückgefahren ist
allerdings jetzt verdeckt durch den
polizeiwagen der hier hinter uns steht
es ist so dass die straße auch eine
kurve macht also der kurfürstendamm
endet hier auf dieser seite und wird als
tenzin vorgesetzt und genau hier auf
höhe der gedächtniskirche ist einer
rechtskurve das heißt also wenn jemand
gerade über die kreuzung fährt dann
fährt er zwangsläufig wieder auf der
anderen seite raus und müsste also
einlenken nach rechts wenn er den weg
auf dem auf dem gehweg fortsetzen wollte
was das wirklich merkwürdig ist wenn es
dann ein unfall war ist warum die
personen dann mit dem wagen dann noch
mal richtig nach rechts gelenkt hat um
eben wieder auf den gehweg letztlich in
dieser schaufensterscheibe zum stehen zu
kommen und nicht geradeaus dann in die
in die mittelinsel die wir vielleicht so
ein bisschen näher man kann sie nicht so
richtig jahren aber wir haben eine
begrünte mittelinsel
das wäre eigentlich der logische weg
wenn man geradeaus fahren würde also da
sind sind einige fragezeichen im moment
an dem in diesem fall was gegen eine
eine vorsätzliche tat spricht ist
vielleicht ein bisschen dass es sich um
einen kleinwagen handeln aber auch der
ich möchte mich das nicht zu mutmaßungen
hinreißen lassen auch der wie wir jetzt
gesehen haben kann tödliche folgen haben
wenn er auf menschen trifft
es geht ein bisschen runter ich habe
vorhin noch mal bei twitter geschaut da
ist von ihm folgen die rede da ist von
terror die rede da ist von vertuschung
die rede dass wir nie erfahren werden
was wirklich sozusagen grund dessen ist
es geht wie immer in solchen situationen
hoch her auch bei uns haben wir die eine
oder andere reaktion aber vor allem
mitgefühl das muss und soll an dieser
stelle auch mal gesagt sein dass es eben
jetzt erstmal darum geht
mitgefühl zu äußern mit dem was da
passiert ist mit dem betroffenen mit den
angehörigen da kämpfen menschen um ihr
leben das ist glaube ich noch nicht der
zeitpunkt irgendwie zu urteilen an
irgendeiner stelle und das andere was
immer wieder auch gesagt wird und was
ich lese ist dass man noch nichts über
den fahrer weiß und auch da wird erst
mal gemutmaßt na ja wenn da nichts
gesagt wird dann wird es schon so und so
sein
bleiben wir da auch erst mal auf dem
boden der tatsachen was weiß man denn zu
stunde über den fahrer außer dass er 60
jahre alt ist
genau das und mit dem was du eben als
vorredner gesagt hast ralf kann ich nur
sagen wir geben das weiter was wir
wissen und erfahren wenn wir es erfahren
und beteiligen uns nicht an an
mutmaßungen meine kollegin fällt mir
gerade noch einen kleinen zettel hoch
ein toter fünf lebensbedrohlich
verletzte ist jetzt die neueste info und
drei schwerverletzte danke steffi also
diese info so wie wir sie jetzt gerade
eben rein bekommen haben eine kollegin
ist hier auch schwört eleganz
herumspricht spricht mit den
einsatzkräften um die fakten zu
recherchieren und was im netz brodelt
das könnte jetzt nicht großartig
kommentieren das haben wir bei anderen
geschehnissen anderen vorfällen auch
schon erlebt wir wissen deswegen über
diesen mann bislang dass er ein clio
gefahren hat und dass er 60 jahre alt
ist dass der boden momentan medizinisch
betreut wird aber vernehmungsfähig sei
aber was er gesagt hat zu seinen motiven
wenn es dann ein motiv gab oder ob es
ein medizinischer notfall oder sonst was
war das wissen wir momentan noch nicht
genommen so carsten ich glaube es ist
mal wieder wichtig genau das auch zu
dokumentieren und auch immer wieder klar
zu kommunizieren
letzte frage noch an dich auch die
vielleicht atmosphärisch wenn du dich um
schaust und wenn du auf das hörst sind
da passanten gibt es schaulustige wie
weiträumig ist das ganze abgesperrt oder
was spürst du wenn du wenn du dich da
umschau aus bei denen die mehr oder
weniger freiwillig und unfreiwillig
zeuge dessen geworden sind was da heute
passiert ist
also um mich herum im moment sind vor
allem einsatzkräfte und journalistinnen
und journalisten in der gedächtniskirche
selber das haben eben auch noch mal von
polizeisprecher erfahren ist eine
psychosoziale betreuung
notfallseelsorger die sich um
augenzeugen kümmern die sind für uns
nicht greifbar ich denke das ist auch
ganz gut weil wir hier keine
traumatisierten menschen vor die kamera
zerren möchten insofern sind die
menschen dies unmittelbar erlebt haben
entweder der eine leider verstorben im
krankenhaus oder werden im moment sozial
medizinisch betreut so ist zumindest
unser infostand alle anderen sind
relativ weit weg die polizei hat diesen
platz hier komplett abgesperrt lässt
niemanden draufsteht auch an den rändern
schwer bewaffnet mit maschinenpistolen
mit helm und probiert eben alle menschen
die nicht mit unmittelbar darüber
berichten oder mit dem vorfall zu tun
haben eben auch auf abstand zu halten
während danke für diese information für
die fakten für die schilderung danke
nach berlin und der tag ist noch nicht
vorbei für uns natürlich bleiben wir
dran um jederzeit berichten zu können
was passiert und was wir wissen
dankeschön erstmal für den moment damit
verabschieden wir uns zum stunde hierbei
zdf heute live mit diesen eindrücken mit
diesen informationen die wir zum stunde
haben danke für euer interesse